[Music]
let's go to danny in boston
massachusetts what's up danny
hi dr d how are you
i'm good doing good how are you just
saving the world i you know what i
probably overstated that a little bit i
don't think i am saving the world but
we're having fun how about you
i am doing good i got i got to talk to
kelly when she called me which was
probably the worst so far like the most
exciting part of this and i'm really
excited to talk to you was she mean to
you
she was amazing i know
i know that's what she does she has all
your folks on the phone thinking she's
so kind and wonderful and then we have
to live with her just kidding she's
incredible she's like the best kelly's
the best
she is he's awesome so what's up how can
i help
yeah so thanks so much for taking my
call
um i think
you know i have uh my i'm struggling
with my my dad
um he's part of a very fundamentalist
christian community and they have a very
specific view on religion and
interpretation of the bible and that
theirs is
the only like right way to live uh it is
it is
there are no other ways
they figured it out
but go ahead
yeah and so i think as i've gotten older
and i have children and i have i have
you know i left that community when i
was
in my early 20s um
i'm struggling to have a relationship
with him he's he's you know he's always
been there for me like he'll talk to me
but every conversation is about
you know it's he always gets he always
gets the little
snippets in and it just feels like a
constant reminder that
he thinks i'm not living my life the way
or raising my kids the way that it
should be and that he has to save me so
and
i'm just really struggling with that
conversation with him
can i just tell you i hate that for
you yeah thank you um
so
go back to childhood you left this group
why'd you leave
was it a belief issue was it the way
they treated you was it the way the
things they said why'd you leave
so
um
so so i i was so
oh
why'd i leave that's a good question
um they
they um
[Music]
just say it out loud say it out loud say
it out loud i know it's hard to i know
hey i know that i'm poking at some deep
deep stuff
as much as you feel comfortable just
saying it out loud
yeah
so they do practice shunning and um at
the time i was gunning married shunning
yep so like if you like dwight and jim
like shun
just like joy and jim yeah listen i've
worked with all kinds of religious
communities my whole career
i've never
i'm not i'm not mocking i never heard of
this so what does that mean like okay we
turn our back on you like we shun
um um it's yep it's intended to be to be
loving like your your your
one of your flock has gone astray and
you know and they'll they'll realize
that they made a mistake and come back
into your loving arms kind of thing i
thought jesus went left the 99 went and
got that other one
that's a good it's a good point yeah
okay so okay so back that thing up so
you no i shouldn't say that out like
don't you don't back that thing up i'm
backing up um so
they shunned
yeah so i i basically so i was married i
was married very young i found myself in
a not great relationship um
so i left but i basically preemptively
personally cut off almost all ties
because i knew the other option was they
were gonna
sort of
do it for me so i when i was 25 i
i essentially like completely started
over now my my dad or my like my he
never
he never cut me off so i still have that
really yeah
i still have that relationship um but
you know it it's um
it you you know like you know they
they feel
that
you're making a tragic mistake right and
then it's their job to try to so that
they give you like you that's in the
back of your mind in every conversation
so the
shunning like
you you got a divorce you got married
young
and there were some things in that
marriage that didn't so you got divorced
and you knew by making this decision to
leave your husband and do something else
with your life
that was also going to cost you your
faith community and so instead of going
through their trial or whatever
um yeah
rick and mary they're going to put you
through you just said deuces i'm out my
guess is there's more to it than that
that you left for bigger reasons than
just they were going to be mean to you
and so you preempted you shunned them
before they shut into you
but
here's what i'm asking
yeah
so there's
we have belief
disagreements with people
so let's take something that's not that
big of a deal like vaccination status
right
and that's me being facetious everyone's
it's a whole thing
um
i get
that somebody looks at the data and
believes the right thing for me to do is
to get vaccinated
i also understand
why someone would say i'm looking at all
of the chaos and saying i want no part
of that
until there's some clarity
and then i also understand
less so but i understand that there's
some guy in the trunk of his car with a
youtube channel with 11 followers and
he's like guess what's happening now and
that you think that's the person who's
discovered truth i get that too right
right all through
but ultimately those are you're gonna
come down on belief issues and you're
gonna hang out and go have a drink with
somebody and then they're gonna be like
bro you know you should be in they're
gonna give you their spiel whatever
their spiel happens to be
those are belief issues fine
that's different
when there's trauma at the bottom of it
so we've heard about when it comes to
vaccinations that
african-american community might have
some challenges because they remember
the tuskegee disaster
and be like hey we're not walking into
some
emergency authorization use thing we've
done this before and y'all used it to
poison i mean you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah in your
case you get to
like this isn't just about hey you
should be going to this church or we're
going to that one
if there's trauma at the bottom of this
if there were things told to you about
how women were or should be or the way
you were treated or the way you were
told to shun people who were hurting
into loving them whatever the things are
if there's a trauma basis here your
body's gonna get set off
and that's different than a belief
difference you hear what i'm saying
yes when somebody believes
i need like we're having a medical
disagreement on the vaccine that's one
thing when somebody believes the
government's trying to kill my kids it's
a different response whether i believe
him or not i get that response is
visceral
right or someone doesn't have the
vaccine i believe my neighbor's trying
to murder my family right i get that
there's a there's a visceralness so
where where are you on this is it just a
belief difference
or did you walk out of this thing
because
there was some trauma there there was
some hurt there
um
i think
so yeah so
i don't i don't know that i i don't
i don't know that i walked out
so the marriage wasn't great like
um
there was anger issues but um which i i
didn't i wanted no part of i wanted
to you know before it escalated so i i
that was part of it but um
the fact hey listen
the fact that you think you owe some
knuckleheaded podcaster on the radio an
explanation as to why you left your
marriage that many years ago
tells me you've got some
that you were told that your job is to
make sure everybody's okay and everybody
approves of your decisions before you
move forward
yeah i mean my dad was
he was pretty angry growing up he never
that's all you're gonna say it's like
hey that's all you got to say that's all
i got to say
so the when i'm talking to you about
what this what this group left in you
and on you
your body's responding right now right
yeah yeah yeah okay
so let's fast forward to the original
question that you asked
here's why we're here
this isn't a matter of
like dad i don't believe in shunning i
believe in hugging and we're just gonna
have to we're gonna have to
we're just gonna have to call a spade a
spade on that one
this is not that
this is your dad is trying to bring you
to something that he thinks in his heart
is gonna help you
yes and that your body knows hurt you
and by your
by the tears being so close
it still hurts you it's still in you
yeah right
there's still unresolved trauma there
that you and i could probably go hang
out and have a beer and talk about it
for a long time right
the point here is this
you do not have to put your body in that
situation and you don't have to put your
kids in that situation because that's
the other part is you don't want your
kids to experience what you experience
true yes and so
the big magic word here is
boundary and that's a simple word but
it's hard because and it's devastating
because you know the other side of
shunning is you lose your dad
and here's what i need you to hear me
say
that's his choice not yours
yes and that sucks
we will go to the ends of the earth to
not put our parents in a position to
choose something over us when we know
they're going to choose the other thing
yeah
we don't want to face that reality so we
just put up with it and put up with it
and put up with it and then all of a
sudden we've imparted that on our kids
and then they do it and then they do it
and they do it and then it gets passed
on generation after generation after
generation
yeah
so somebody has to stare this sucker
down and say
if you bring up this again
you're my dad
i love you
um it sounds to me like you've got some
stuff you need to work through with a
counselor about your dad
um
not probably 100 chance 100
are you married now
yes yes good guy
amazing i'm very blessed if he was
behind you and heard me say you should
probably go to counselor and get work on
some of your dad's stuff he would
probably be nodding his head vigorously
right
he would be very supportive yes i'm sure
he would so
for you
go do that okay okay
and there's gonna be some stuff about
your dad you're gonna have to face it's
gonna be ugly and messy and gross and
you don't wanna think about it because
you love him and he is a good guy
but you got to stare that stuff down
because your body knows
yeah and when he calls your heart beats
a little bit faster and when he says
he's coming over
your heart beats a lot faster and you go
a little bit more limbic and you're a
little bit more tense and you hold cups
a little bit tighter and all of that
energy and electricity gets passed on
and passed on to past on and i want you
to be able to sleep
and we we did have
a conversation
and it was exactly kind of how you
describe like i just i just snapped like
i come i felt like after it was over
i was like what what beings took over my
body like words were coming out that i
didn't even like i like things i felt
that were buried so deep i don't know
that i ever acknowledged and i i asked
him i was like i can't like i can't have
i can't can't keep having these
conversations with you like i need to
have a relationship that revolves
that's more than this he's had some
health issues so it's it's been him
almost dying or
it's been you know this for the past
like three years and um
he he he doesn't he doesn't under he's
very
and like he tries to understand and he
just but he doesn't and i and i if i
feel like i tried i'm not good at
boundaries i know that i feel like i
tried really hard and now i'm feeling so
uncomfortable because i feel like
there's this unsettled problem between
us and i don't
do that so listen
there is an unsettled problem between
the two of you
and you can't fix it
and that's the
that's the heartbreaking part you can't
solve it
he can because he's dead
yeah and i know that hurts
you can't fix that one
and
i just thought of this just now
but i can imagine a world where your
body
your brain your heart feels like a
boundary protecting you and your kids
is akin to shunning and some part of you
swore i will never shun anybody for
anything for any reason
and so here's what i want you to think
through
a boundary is not a shun
a boundary is you simply saying this is
what i need to be okay and if you are
willing to help me be well
or to love me enough or to respect me
enough or to
have enough dignity be a person of
character enough to listen to the things
that i need to be well
i am yours and you're mine
and if you choose
your things over the things i'm telling
you out loud
i need to feel safe and feel well
then you are choosing to not be a part
of my life and that breaks my heart but
that's your choice
you see how everything about this is his
choice
except for the the boundaries except for
your choice to take care of you and your
kids and your husband
great
and i hate hate hate that you have to do
this but you do
yeah
i hate it for you
i'm okay i am
whenever my six-year-old daughter is
sprinting through the house and all of a
sudden we just hear wham and she crashes
it she'll you'll hear this i'm okay
exactly she's clearly not okay she
doesn't want us to get up and go see
what she's trying to sneak into the room
you're clearly not okay danny and listen
it's okay to not be okay
you're okay this is gonna hurt
it's gonna hurt
and that's still okay
it's right
yes
yeah so here's what i want you to do
you've heard me say this a million times
i'm gonna say it a million more times
i want you
to write a letter to your dad
okay about everything
all of it
you can even have sections called good
stuff and bad stuff i don't care what it
is
as a part of the letter at the end i
want you to say so now what
and that's what i want you to articulate
after you've written the good stuff the
stuff that you love about them actually
you've really i want you to like you
just said i felt like i was possessed
something took over me i want you to
bring that i want you let your limbic
brain take back over for a minute i want
you to go there
yeah and then i want you to write down
so here's what's not acceptable in my
life anymore i'm choosing
to be well and here's what that's going
to look like for me
and then i want you to read this letter
out loud to your husband
okay
because he doesn't know it all does he
you know nope
why don't you read it out loud to him
okay
and then i want you to call a counselor
and make an appointment
yeah okay i mean i need the counselor to
help me write the letter it's the help
idea is terrifying so it is no super
challenge
you may have to write two or three you
may have to write two or three yeah
okay
you may have to yeah
there's a moment that it's gonna happen
that you're gonna realize your dad is
somebody who is
intentionally
disregarding
your requests
for how you can best be loved
and that disregard is
violence it's immaturity and it has to
stop
and most of us
hope that our parents will be the ones
to stop doing violence
and often we're the ones that have to
put up the boundaries and say no more
i mean yeah yeah it all makes sense yeah
it's all very
logical
i wish i had seven easy steps to fix
this i don't yeah i need the baby stops
for uh exactly exactly
well hey buy my new book and
i wish i had a man i wish i did
hey but here's the thing hang on the
line here's what i'm gonna do okay i'm
going to um austin's
kelly's at home she doesn't work on with
these days just kidding she's actually
not she's actually sick she's not doing
she's not she's not feeling well uh we
miss her um but austin uh is here and i
want you to stay on the line we're gonna
get you get your information and i'm
gonna get you hooked up for the
pre-order of my new book that will walk
through these things with you
and um you have that but i'm only doing
that if you promise you'll write that
letter read it to your husband and make
a counseling appointment cool
i promise same team same dream
same team same team same dream i'm
trying to think of the cheesiest things
i could say i can't even say it with a
straight face all right cool all right
danny you're awesome awesome awesome
thanks for calling